I read your book I want to say six eight
months ago when I first bought it and uh
it it it changed me a lot because I had
just gotten through like a pretty rough
relationship girlfriend was cheating on
me uh you know how you find out she was
Che on you uh well I broke up with her
and then next day you know I broke up
with her for other reasons that just not
following my frame you know I was trying
to do my own thing um and then I found
out she was uh going on dates and you
know hanging out with one of my best
friends friends so you know spinning
plates but uh yeah and so that wasn't
even that bad you know I don't have any
confirmation or anything that uh you
know she was him or any oh that
she was uh you know banging him or
anything like that but uh you know I got
into your content I started take my work
a little bit more seriously I run a
couple side businesses I trade full-time
I manage a small ATM business MH um you
know and so uh you know I got into
another relationship with this other
girl you know
eight you know pretty big girl and uh I
started off real fine had good
frame you know made her fit into my
frame made her get rid of sorts of
piercings and stuff like that fit to my
schedule lost frame like four months
into the relationship and then she
actually went and Che it on me with
somebody else you know so I'm I'm back
on the grind now realize I need to get
uh my stuff done so right now what I do
I mention the last two girls you've been
dealing with cheated on you yeah yeah
pretty disaster I think I lost frame I
think it's that simple I think when uh I
got into the relationship you know my
brother my entire friends group they all
have long-term girlfriends they've been
dating for you know four or five years
and so I thought you know you'll find
were these women a little bit older okay
so the first one was
much yeah so I'm 24 now M first one was
20 okay second one was 26 so I went from
dating somebody younger than me to
dating somebody older than
me um yeah and so I think just what
happened is you know I get into the
relationship and then I think ah she's
the one and uh I start to you know I
don't want to say I definitely don't
lose confidence I get more confident you
know when when I'm in a relationship but
uh you know I just think um I I allowed
my happiness to rely on whether or not
she was happy and that's something I'll
never do again you know I I have to be
happy myself uh I didn't even really
call in for relationship advice I know
that's what this uh no that's fine but I
wanted to talk about something since you
since you've brought it up because
because I added another red flag to the
red flag chapter there's 21 and you know
by the way you can the the email list
has it updated so if you guys are on the
email list you can download the news
version of it with the extra red flag
but one of them is women that won't
follow your lead and enter your frame
and I think that you can test for that
really early on you don't have to wait
six months to find out that she's not
going to follow your lead you know you
don't have to wait eight months to find
out that she's not going to enter your
frame and be a compliment to your life
and try to be the focus of it you can
find that out pretty early on like a
simple test like hey babe you know
before you come over tonight do me solid
grab that bottle bottle red wine that I
like simple thing you know just to test
her to see if she's going to apply with
a simple request because as life goes on
with this girl you know if you're if
you're going to want her to be a
compliment to your life you're going to
have her doing things with you and for
you right so you just dismiss them early
on you know before you even get into the
you know the hey where do we stand I dig
your Vibe I don't see anybody else right
now you know we can be exclusive sort of
thing and again you know she's the one
that ask that question that's why I
added the extra red flag in that chapter
so decide those things early on rather
than waiting months into it because I
guarantee you it like you probably
notice it happened a few times where you
try to set some sort of boundary or said
no and you know she pushed Beyond it and
that's simply a chck that's not going to
respect your boundaries and believe it
or not this is actually pretty
interesting so you know I've been
following your channel for a little
while and uh you know I read your book
and um I actually did both of those
things you know I would uh I did the
exact trick that you were talking about
you know just uh oh left my wallet in
the truck and you get this coffee yeah
or you know i' she'd be on her way over
I'd be like oh can you stop at Duncan
you know get me a breakfast sandwich in
the morning on a Saturday you know
occasionally kind of test her to see if
she's willing to go out of her way you
know to do things with me and I did that
with uh both of them you know so that
was like you know pass they did both of
them passed continu that test
continuously though uh you know what
maybe not continuously throughout the
whole relationship I would say early on
like it changes as time goes on right
right as a relationship develops it's
hey you know you're going to the grocery
store to get some stuff can you grab my
dry cleaning while you're there you know
here's a receipt yeah yeah and I think
it's as the relationship goes on the
longer and longer I date them I I test
them less versus the testing needs to
get more intense see this is a great
mistake that that guys make with
long-term relationship is they don't
realize the amount of work that's
involved there's less work involved to
spin plates and date multiple women
simultaneously there's just less work
because if you're a top shelf guy and
you've got options it's pretty easy
because if they just misbehave or they
don't align with something you're doing
then you don't have time for them you
know you make time for somebody else
whereas with a chick in a long-term
relationship you know if early on she
was doing things like I don't know
making your bed in the morning before
she left and she stopped doing that then
that's when you have to basically say
hey you know the things that got you in
the door here you know the things that
uh you know help me choose you were what
you were doing early on you can't be
stopping that stuff right like you have
to continue doing that so you have to
hold them accountable to certain
standards so so that guidance that you
have to do is is work and that's more
work than just being like I'll just call
the other girl sort of thing right you
don't care because there's no investment
at that point I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the fulllength podcast you can find that
over here that clip's from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out